Yaron Yaniv, thank you
so much for me joining
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me, Michael.
- Wonderful.
- It's great to be here.
Okay. So, I messed up again.
It’s happening a little bit more
often that I’d like it
That we begin talking,
and then I just forget to record
because I’m already fascinated
about what we’re talking about.
But I have the pleasure of speaking
now to somebody who was
one of the people responsible for
the architecture of Visa's
revenue streams.
Just to put that in perspective,
that’s a company that deals with
over a billion transactions a day.
A billion.
So quite a significant role,
but besides that
office of the CTO
of Silicon Valley Bank,
and LP at J-Ventures,
which I’m also a part of,
so I’ll repeat the question
that I had before. Yaron,
what does it take to lead the
enterprise architecture
for Visa's revenues streams?
Yeah, great question, Michael.
And you can probably guess being
a part of Visa,
pretty massive company
in more than 200 countries
all over the globe,
and dealing with that mass,
dealing with that volume
brings in huge, huge,
huge challenges.
So, some of them are related to
the ability to process that amount
of transaction in such a short
time span, right? Every day,
a billion plus transactions,
making sure that you process it.
[crosstalk]
Sorry?
In over 200 countries,
you mentioned which is -
In over 200 countries.
In over 200 countries, yeah.
All the protocols and
Mind-blowing.
And what’s even more mind-blowing
is that you would need to apply
more than 10,000 rules to each
and every one of these 1 billion
transactions and make sure that
it’s taking into account in terms
of how you bill it
and how you service it,
and how you price it,
and how you aggregate it,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So, this by itself,
is two pretty massive challenges.
Add that to the fact that
everything needs to be
well-secured, compliant.
Everything has to be audited
to the cent and everything has to
really work and play as in
a concert with no
disruptions whatsoever.
That really adds
quite a lot to the mix.
I have to say that I recently
developed a software that is able
to make a thousand small
calculations in a few seconds
with microservices and all
that sexy stuff.
And I was so proud of myself.
And now, I just feel so small
when you’re talking
about 10,000 rules
over each transaction
as a part of a billion.
So, you have my appreciation.
Everything is relative in life.
[laughs]
That’s the first lesson
from the stock.
Fantastic. Okay, continue. Sorry.
No. No problem at all.
So, all these challenges
and why you need to continue
and develop the infrastructure
in your software stack
and the ability to innovate
and to be open to innovation.
Dealing, of course,
with very, very
some of the systems
that are super legacy,
modernizing that stack,
fostering the ability to open up
and be able to serve different
organizations,
internal and external.
That was quite a wild ride.
My Visa days
- Yeah, no
I’m sure.
So, give me a little bit of
the day-to-day of
Is it stressful, first?
Is it stressful managing
such a critical piece
of the financial puzzle?
There’s a lot of
stress involved, yes.
Again, revenue systems,
you have to deal with money.
And money is really,
really critical.
So, we got into situations
when we were, at some occasions,
missing even a few
pennies here and there,
even a few dollars here and there.
Things did not match.
Things did not settle.
And because of Visa reputation
and the commitment
to be always 100% up and accurate,
there were some stressful
situations where we needed
to make sure that everything
is well-reconciled
and we were able to send
the settlement files
and payments over,
essentially charge,
the different clients
the right amount.
So, definitely some situations
there in addition to the ability
to process that volume
within a short time span.
How many people are
how many people were involved
with this whole engineering feat?
You know, there were not huge
amounts of engineers involved.
I don’t want it to sound like
we had 10,000 people
on the ground essentially working
to get this machinery going on.
It was around 100 to 150
Wow. That’s -
across the board.
Incredibly impressive.
And I have to ask because I’m
What am I staring at?
Where are you
right now in the world?
So, this is actually
Tongariro Pass
which is northern part
northern island off New Zealand.
And I actually have a habit
of keeping my virtual background
in Zoom rotating across
all the different hikes
I did across my 40-plus years
on planet earth.
Incredible.
What was your favorite hike?
That’s one of the top 5 for sure.
[laughs]
It’s like asking somebody,
"Who’s your favorite child?"
I like them all.
They’re just different
Is the lake actually green
when you’re there?
No, it’s just a
It’s kind of a
looks like it’s green,
but it’s not.
It’s actually
Okay, great.
Very talented photographer.
Definitely, definitely.
So Yaron, talk to me
now, a little about
Silicon Valley Bank.
What is that and what is your role
over there as part
of the office of the CTO?
Sure. Going from Visa
to Silicon Valley Bank,
I needed to do some shifting.
And Silicon Valley Bank
is a commercial bank
which the population
that it serves is
innovation economy.
In fact, 65% of all
the innovation economy
money in the US
is being processed
through Silicon Valley Bank.
And we have representation
over all the main innovation hubs
So, we have a branch
in Israel and in
big one in the UK,
and in Canada, and Germany.
Wherever there is
innovation spurring,
you’re going to find
Silicon Valley Bank there.
What does that mean,
a bank that is
that it’s main customer base
is innovation?
What does that mean?
- So, we have
We have a set of unique
products that is really tailored
and geared towards start-ups.
Private equity firms.
And when we're saying start-ups,
it’s everywhere from series A,
series B, C, all the way up
to established companies
that are already in the NASDAQ
and are already public companies.
So, we do have products that are
tailored towards that cohort.
We're specialized in
products that are tailored
toward that cohort.
And that’s really
the secret sauce ...
Right. And then what
so how does that differ
in the mindset when you’re
creating, when you’re working
at an organization
that is tailored to innovation
with all the dynamics
that it brings with it, right?
Because I’m
'cause I guess different
from the average citizen
or the average company
that has a bank account.
Start-ups go up.
They go down.
They raise 10 million.
They lose 12 million.
So, how does that mindset shift?
Exactly. Exactly right.
You just said it.
So, you’re talking about
a cohort of clients that is
very different because
an early-stage founder,
which has a team of 10,
has very different needs
from a ... client
that is a well-established company
with 500 employees
that runs on $100 million cycle.
So, they have different needs,
but they are all entrepreneurs.
They all have a need to get banking
financial products from us.
So, that requires us to essentially
have different facets of products
and different lines of products
that can cater towards
these different sectors.
In addition, we’re working
with entrepreneurs.
We all know what entrepreneurs
are after, right?
They need things that work fast.
They need things that work slick.
They need things that are
tailored to their needs.
And they want to do that
from their mobile device.
- Right.
- So
having a stack, having products
that are tailored towards what
entrepreneurs are after
and their set of mind
and of course,
they want things that change.
I mean, today, it’s this.
Tomorrow, it’s that.
They don’t want to wait
for 12 months for somebody
to come in and come up
with a product that’s tailored
for an ever-changing market.
Right. So, you’re very
strategically positioned within
this financial tech industry.
What really excites you about it?
Why choose to go into banks?
With your tech skillsets,
I mean you’re wanted in every
tech company in the world.
So, why specifically
banking and finance?
So, I think because of that
very close interface
with entrepreneurs.
Hmm.
So, Silicon Valley Bank sees
itself not only as a bank.
We’re not that
an ATM, you go and
get money from,
and that’s it.
We’re actually
building relationships.
So, I have the opportunity
as an architect to speak to many,
many, many companies
Really?
and explain to them
and work with them,
and kind of give them an insight
on what does it take to work with
regulated financial institutes.
That is very precious information
and something that
that companies really, really value.
So, we do that.
We have the ability to connect
between different clients of ours
because we know that client A
might be well-integrated
with client B.
And sometimes, we even adopt
technologies that are
coming in from our clients,
which we always look at favorably.
- Incredible.
- So you
get that ability to really
work within that
innovation economy,
within the innovation ecosystem.
That was something that was
really appealing to me.
And that’s something I
For example, Visa was
very different in that sense.
Right. And I’m guessing
it’s also different number of
employees around the world
and the magnitude
must be different, right?
Because Visa is just
it’s crazy.
A juggernaut. Exactly.
So, Silicon Valley Bank
is a medium-sized bank.
Fairly small, smaller presence
in California and in other
areas in the world.
But I think the culture also,
because of the need
and the ability to speak with
and engage with our entrepreneurs,
the culture within
the bank is very open,
very honest, very authentic.
- Right.
- These are things
that I really do appreciate.
But I have to really
get to the bottom of this
because you’re saying
that you’re a technology architect
within Silicon Valley Bank.
So, it’s an engineering
leadership role, correct?
So, the interesting thing with
what I’m doing is
I’m sitting right in the junction
between engineering,
business, and product.
And that’s my sweet spot.
Right. So, talk
so that sweet spot,
I’d love to just learn
a little bit more about
what it means to talk
to the entrepreneurs
and to your customers
while having all
of these different hats on.
Absolutely.
And I think what it does
and what it requires you to do is
to really think
like a product manager.
Think like an engineer.
Think like a businessperson
when you are trying to roll
out technology changes
and when you speak
with entrepreneurs.
So, you bring in that multiple
angles to the conversation.
So, if you think
like a product manager
What features, what makes
more sense to invest in?
What will kind of turn the needle
or move the needle.
And when you think
like an engineer it's
how do you build your stack
in an open way with your APIs
that you want to expose
so partners like
Silicon Valley Bank
can work with you easily?
Where is your encryption of
the data that you’re going to
save your sensitive data?
Those types of specific areas
that you can bring to the table.
So, you bring in a meal
that’s made out of a few courses,
essentially, not just the
one-dimensional angle.
Yeah no, definitely.
So, you’re not just drawn
to the entrepreneurs
at Silicon Valley Bank, but
also as a part
of venture capital,
and you’re an LP
at the J-Ventures Fund.
So, where does that
interest come from?
And how do you balance
that interest with being inside
of a big corporate?
Great question.
So, the fact that I’ve been working
with entrepreneurs in the last
four years certainly helped me
kind of getting close
to that ecosystem.
Right.
I think that it really triggered
my interest into the VC community
and into the capital community,
capital funding community.
I also feel very strong
around the mission
that J-Ventures
has with keeping that
the gap or closing the gap between
Israelis and American Jews.
Of course.
We definitely see
opportunities there
and I’m excited about that mission.
So, a combination
of those two together
that’s really what was driving me
over towards J-Ventures.
Very happy so far.
A hundred percent.
No, no. Me, too.
But do you have that sort of like
irkness or those like goosebumps
when you see the entrepreneurs
and do you have that sense of,
“Well, maybe one day,
I want to do
go on an adventure
like that as well"?
Or are you happy
with the intersection of business
and executive technology
within a large corporation
while investing?
Can’t lie Michael.
I always have something
at the back of my mind that says,
“How about that idea?
How about this idea?”
So, I do have a few things
in the back of my mind
but the opportunity
just didn’t present itself yet.
And it’s all about timing
and the right time,
and the right
the right location.
So, my brother by the way,
is an entrepreneur.
So, he’s kind of
adding a lot of fire or a lot of
oil into that fire as well.
At all the Shabbat dinners I'm sure.
Exactly. So, it’s somewhere there.
Hasn’t been materialized yet,
but life is short, you know?
Let’s see what
we do in the future.
A hundred percent.
No, that’s really fantastic.
And I’d love to sort of shift
and understand a little
bit better about this
about fintech and about the
financial world as it is.
I know nothing about it
except for the fact that I know
how to swipe my credit card
and hopefully check pretty often
to make sure that my
balance is above zero.
I don’t know much.
Give me a little bit of your
insight into what’s happening
in 2020 with finance
and how consumers
are interacting with their banks.
And where are we headed from here?
Sure. And digital is
definitely the big thing.
Digital, meaning that you
don’t want to call your bank.
You don’t want to send
your bank an email.
You want to be able
to interact with your bank
through digital means,
through digital applications.
If you own a company,
if you own a start-up
or a private equity company,
you want to have APIs,
which are ways to interact
with your bank without needing
to even use a mobile app.
You just hook in your systems
through APIs and you’ve got
everything done automatically
for some of your needs.
So, digital and automation
are really big right now
in the ecosystem.
In the commercial ecosystem,
even more, right?
So, if you do have a business,
if you need to do payment,
if you want to be able
to shift money in between accounts,
if you want to be able to
pay different bills,
you want all that
to be very automated,
very streamlined,
very simple for you.
You also want to have
different payments
and different ways to pay.
And depending on
how you want to pay
sometimes you’re willing
to pay more to get
things done quicker.
Sometimes, you have the ability
to wait with some of your payments.
So, you want to have the ability
to choose between
different types of payments.
You don’t want just
to do wires 100% of the time.
Yeah.
Cards is another great example.
Cards are blowing up.
I mean the cards industry
is just, and Visa of course,
is a main beneficiary out of this.
But the cards industry
and the products on cards
are right exploding.
So loyalty and the ability to do
so many things with
virtual cards.
Pay your vendors,
pay your employees
with virtual cards.
That’s been a very
hot topic as well.
So, it really is a lot around
digital, around payments,
around automation.
That’s what I would say
are three main trends
of what we see around.
And how does trust
play into all of this,
especially as things are
transitioning to paperless,
or they have transitioned,
but in some parts of the world
I was recently visiting Mexico
with a friend and we were sitting
with one of the top start-ups
there who are now helping
digitalize the banking
system in Mexico.
And it turns out that most people
there don't have credit cards yet
and don’t have digital banking yet.
So, how do you
how much does trust play into
this whole transition
that the world is going through?
I think, so we’re a
commercial bank
so we don’t work
with individuals.
We work with -
- Right.
commercial entities.
But I can look at trust
from maybe a different
angle for you.
When we talk about identity
Yes.
and the ability
So, think about it, right
We’re in a world
where fake reality
is very much becoming
almost the real reality in many,
many different occasions.
And you hear about use cases
and occasions where folks
were kind of pretending
to be person X
and calling person Y,
and telling him to just wire
a million dollars to that specific address
and they were sure it was the CEO,
et cetera, et cetera.
So, being able to transact
financially in a safe way is huge.
Right.
And for that,
there are different technologies.
Some of them are coming in
in a pretty big way,
such as voice recognition,
such as biometrics behavior
or behavioral biometrics,
and other ways
that we are also thinking of
of how to do that
transactional journey,
how to do that identification,
multi-factor authentication.
Yeah.
All of that good stuff
to make sure that you are you
when you try to transact
with us, is critical.
And the most important thing
is how you do that
without putting a huge
burden on the user that
all he want is just to move
$100 between his accounts.
Exactly. Exactly.
Yaron, that’s just fascinating.
We do have to end soon,
but I’d love to ask you
the last question, which is
three words that you would
use to describe yourself.
Wow, three words. All right.
So let me think.
We said two to four, so
Three is a good median.
Happy median.
So, how about we go with humble?
Yes.
Very important to me,
very important for me
to be in a place
where people are humble.
Curious, which really goes
hand in hand with humble
being humble and really wanting
to learn and understand more.
And I think I'm very focused.
So, I got this maniacal focus
that I actually jump on things
and I make sure that things
are done and very, very
important not to get distracted.
So, that would be
my three key words.
Yaron, I think it’s incredible
and I can’t even imagine
what it’s like to even be
a part of a team that
let alone lead it,
that manages this
infrastructure of
Oh my god.
Today, it’s a billion
transactions a day.
I’m gonna have to go back
to my drawing board
of a thousand calculations.
Yeah you scale that baby up.
You scale it up.
I love it, Yaron. Toda raba.
Thank you very much.
- Great. Thanks.
- And I’ll see you around J-Ventures.
Thank you for having me.
- Take care.
- Have a good one.
- Bye-bye.